earlier this year we have filed
complaints against seven companies those
are data brokers ad tech companies and
companies that do credit scoring and the
reason for our complaints and the reason
why we focused on these companies that
are really not a household named names
to most people is that it is currently
impossible for most people to understand
how they're being tracked and profiles
and in whose hands all of this data ends
up as part of this research I asked one
of these tracking companies a company
called contest that many of you probably
haven't heard of but that has certainly
heard of you for all of my data so what
you see here this is a heavily edited
and deliberately blurred version of my
browsing history so what you see here
are those are the websites I've opened
timestamps device information this is
work-related so it's quite sensitive
sometimes it also includes inferred data
a predicted value for my gender whether
I have children my income and with all
of this came partner data from all other
all kinds of companies different data
brokers who placed me into infuriating
categories like heavy alcohol spender at
home or affinity for baby products and
nappies here's what's so very
fascinating about that data except that
it's a lot of data some of it is heavily
personal and some of it is very wrong
but what's so fascinating is that all of
this data is from one cookie from one
browser that was placed on one of my
devices this is why today we have just
published right now research about how a
very different tracking company tracks
people on apps that are built for
Android and we've spell focused
especially on how Facebook tracks people
who do not have a Facebook account
earlier this year research by the
University of Oxford showed that 42
percent of apps of free apps in the
Google Play Store in the US and the UK
should could share data with Facebook
and what's interesting is that this
makes Facebook the second largest
tracker after Google's parent company
alphabet with this research that we just
published we wanted to build on this and
show what exactly this data sharing
looks like particularly for people who
don't have a Facebook account the reason
we focused on Facebook and not Google or
any of the other tracking companies is
because the very fact that apps like a
period tracker or an LED flashlight
shares data with Facebook in the first
place will come as a surprise for many
people and especially for those who have
made a conscious decision not to be on
Facebook here's what we did so we took
Oxford University's research and make a
few sites the time they gave us a copy
of their this and they gave us a list of
all of the apps of the top 5,000 apps
that use Facebook SDK we chose the
number of the law or some of the largest
partners and we also chose a few apps
that were the one had sensitive data
like they were either to do with
religion or they were to do with health
or some other stuff and he took the
outside of that selection because
utility apps may also have information
about other apps so this is the 34 that
we chose and you can see it's a real mix
of both big big-name applications you
know like Spotify
indeed and then much smaller
applications that are made by more indie
developers either just games and they
make that sort of thing and put all of
these apps have over 10 million ace
tools and we chose apps that had decent
install basis because we this isn't this
isn't really about the apps themselves
and developers we're not Curtis like
we're not here to criticize developers
for the way they made their apps this is
all about the SDK and the way it
transmits data with or without user
concerns so it could take you quickly
through our analysis methodology at
Android Nexus 5 running Android 8.1
connected through a virtual machine
running mi tiempo Roxy which is a manual
middle protesting tool
I didn't transparently so the app didn't
know that it was being intercepted and
we had a look at what the data was
things going between the app and
Facebook
so our first finding was that over 61%
of the apps we tested automatically
transferred data before the user has any
other likely they literally just open
the app so I was 21 out of 34 so for
example his kayak and as you'll see
pretty much immediately from when the
app is it clicked that first request is
straight to facebook.com and it sends a
whole load of other data tools many
other companies
besides thank you I could let it go on
for a while but ultimately you end up
from their home screen which is kind of
amusing because they've got this at the
bottom of it which is don't worry we'll
never share anything without your
permission
[Music]
so so let's take a look at some of this
seems like slightly more detail this is
a this is pretty standard this is a
vkv Russian social network and their act
is pretty typical of how the SDK is
implemented and I'm guessing probably in
the default state which is the app
doesn't math initialize when a SDK is
first loads saying STK initialized and
then when the app is in the foreground
it's got activated up and then when the
app goes to background it sends a
message saying deactivate to that and
then it comes back and we close the app
it says deactivate to that so you can
actually start to profile like how long
the users using about how often they're
opening me out this kind of stuff if you
look at some this data if you're able to
see it well clearly it got a unique ID
that is what we proposed personal data
because since you need to attach to your
browsing and whatever your app usage and
then some other extraneous data in here
that's also quite in quite telling
it's got a it's got stuff like what
version of Android you're running what
the device you're running on or your
keyboard locale localization is you know
what your timezone you're getting quite
a picture just from this one app of wait
for someone and then it doesn't take
much to go beyond that so a second
finding is some apps also routinely send
Facebook data that is incredibly
detailed sometimes sensitive this isn't
a particularly new finding though I've
seen other people's so a good shout out
to Exodus privacy you also to report it
about the baby plus app and and mobile
she's who also earlier this week I think
reported about the pregnancy Plus app
that sends granular data so some
examples we found in our data so so the
top example here is kayak and kayak
sends your entire search to Facebook
every time you do a search in their app
which is lovely so and it's interesting
what they send because it's not just
it's not just for the content of your
search there's also some others stuff
like your user score whatever that is
it's got observe for skated session IDs
and all sorts of other things that
they're sending to Facebook the other
one that's on the bottom here is the
King James Bible
and it's quite typical of a lot of ways
that app developers implement the SDK
and allows them to track your usage
through the app so this one when I
originally tested it they've actually
made their data slightly less granular
but when I originally tested this out
they actually told you watch verse and
passage of the Bible you'd read which is
the what Facebook needs to know so and
then the last bit is the actual
advertising data that Facebook uses and
this is a request to their ad network
and some slightly interesting stuff that
comes from here is that you know like
the device is on charge the map the
battery percentage is full there's free
space and this isn't this isn't even the
most comprehensive example I've seen the
other data on there such as
accelerometer positions although a
slight interesting thing again all
linked with the VF ID and everything
here is it's got at the top there copper
false which is the Americans child
protection retired Privacy Act and it's
somehow decided that I'm not a child
even though it never asked me so so and
yeah it's crucial to remember that this
happens whether you're a Facebook user
or you're not on Facebook whether you're
logged in or you're not logged in so
it's making profiles are being made
regardless of whether you're have a
Facebook account or you don't have a
Facebook account well you have to use
some of these apps and a profile is
being built potentially
so what is this matter what any of this
matter obviously only focus on the data
that ABS transmits and we can't possibly
say with definite affinity how this data
is being used but here's what's really
interesting is that our first finding is
that the vast majority of apps share
data the second it's opened and the data
that is being transmitted indicates what
kinds of app you use when you use them
combined with a unique ad ID and knowing
what kinds of apps somebody uses and
when can give quite a detailed picture
of someone's life so these are four apps
that we have actually tested the first
one is a Muslim prayer app the second
one is a period tracker indeed as a job
search app and my talking tom is a
children's app so what kind of person
could that be that looks like a person
who is likely Muslim likely female
likely looking for a job and likely have
who likely has a child so in our
analysis the apps that automatically
transmit data it all comes together with
a Google Ad ID that's a user resettable
unique ID that's also in our previous
work on data brokers and ad tech
companies is primarily used for
connecting different profiles together
even though we don't know what is
happening to this data it would be
pretty straightforward to link it up
there's also a second reason why this
data is uniquely interesting and that is
knowing what kinds of apps hundreds of
millions of people use and when they use
them gives gives quite a unique insight
into the Android app market so if
combined event data such as app
installed SDK initialized and deactivate
app from different apps offer a very
detailed insight into the usage behavior
of hundreds of millions of people on ads
and again we have deliberately focused
on AB that have a lot of installs at
least 10 million and some have even 500
million installs so combined we're
looking at over 2 billion installs and
the kinds of data that these app share
that really matters because it's a lot
of data
the question though is why do so many
apps share data with Facebook the second
that the app opens there are obviously
many reasons and some of these are even
good reasons why abused the why apps use
third-party tracking and as decays such
as the Facebook SDK so what the Facebook
SDK for Android does it allows app
developers to integrate their apps with
Facebook's platform and it contains a
number of main components such as
analytics ads or login so this is the
reason why apps or some apps choose to
use the SDK now here's where it gets a
bit complicated Facebook places this
sole responsibility on apps to ensure
that the data that they collect and
ultimately transmitted to Facebook has
been obtained legally and we've reached
out to Facebook and they confirm to us
again that it places a legal and
contractual obligation on the developer
who they see as the data controller to
get consent as it is required for the
use from users before sharing data with
Facebook via the SDK however the kind of
data sharing that we've observed in the
majority of apps is the default
implementation of the SDK that's nothing
we discovered that's clearly admitted by
Facebook in the QuickStart guide for
Android so when you use the SDK its
default implementation automatically
transmits data since May and what
happens in May GDP are entered into
force lots of developers have been
falling back reports about the SDK on
the right you see one of them but there
are many you can search Facebook's
developer platform for them this one
from July 24th somebody complains that
they wanted to integrate the login but
the moment the app opens it transmits
people's ad ID and they're not allowed
to do this so the reason why developers
complained is that when apps share data
the second they're opened you are unable
to ask people for their explicit and
ambiguous permission which is the bar
for consent that gdpr requires so
Facebook released the feature and that
feature delays what they call the
automatic event logging but that feature
was only released in
June and we in our conversation with
Facebook prior to this publication
Facebook confirmed to us in writing that
prior to the introduction of this delay
option developers were able to disable
the transmission of data but that
doesn't include something they call a
signal that the SDK has been initialized
and this is exactly what we've observed
in our research and just as a reminder
the signal that the SDK has been
initialized that's data that that gives
a strong indication somebody's what kind
of apps somebody uses and when they are
using this combined with their Google
Ads ID the big question is of course is
this even legal and we have a very long
section in our reports that explains
this in a lot of detail because it is
very complicated but what this analysis
shares is that we think that the
responsibility is a lot more complicated
than saying this is entirely the
responsibility of apps so since we've
done this analysis in the UK and the UK
is still a member of the European Union
and has implemented the gdpr that's one
legal framework that applies we also
looked at the e privacy and we also
looked at competition law in the
underlying CMAs who has with what kind
of responsibilities so the question is
what should Android developers do well
of your privacy game again we looked at
large apps that have lots of significant
resources at the very least apps should
comply with relevant privacy laws and
I'm saying this so clearly because we've
seen apps that have like two paragraphs
of privacy policies and that is
unambiguously non-compliant but we also
sort of like you have a responsibility
like to not transmit data that doesn't
need to be transmitted so data
minimization and giving people an actual
choice and it was quite interesting we
reached out to all of the 21 apps that
automatically transmit data as well as
those that share much more detailed data
and was very fascinating to see the very
different responses that we got from
companies some we had the impression
didn't fully understand the SDK and what
the SDK does when
some had a very different interpretation
of what they should do legally somewhat
didn't really didn't realize that this
is happening and promised out to update
their apps we need to give some credit
to sky sky now this is the only app that
got back to us within three days and
said thanks very much we for immediately
updated our app and this is no longer
happening we haven't been able to test
it
and there's also been an app to the
Weather Channel they updated the app
immediately after we tested it in
December but basically the responses
were quite very varied and the general
impression is that apps that have a
gigantic user base need to do a better
job at the same time however I think our
research also gives some thoughts to
rethink third-party tracking on apps
even if our legal analysis says it's a
little bit more complicated the Facebook
says the responsibility is with apps so
integrating if you at the moment you
integrated a third-party tracker this
comes with risks and so the question is
do you really need to integrate the SDK
and if you integrate it can you do it
selectively you shouldn't assume that
the default implementation is compliant
and whenever you implement it be very
fair and transparent to both users about
exactly what it is you're doing and how
you're collecting data so what should
Facebook do so previously by design and
by default is not just a principle for
data protection but it's also something
that's quite relevant here
we don't really Facebook got back to us
explaining the many different ways that
developers are able to delay the kind of
logging and orell alike or change the
way that the SDK works but to the best
of our knowledge there's no good reason
why the default shares data
automatically so if you're selling a
product that allows people to send data
to you and you make place the
reliability on the people who do this
data sharing why shouldn't this be
privacy friendly by design and by
default there's also something
interesting that happened in both the
responses that we got from Facebook and
also Google's initial reaction to the
research that was published by by the
Oxford researchers earlier this year and
that was sort of like what other
companies also tracked people and
Facebook spent a lot of time in
parliamentary hearings this year and we
had the pleasure to watch all of them
and in one of these hearings of Facebook
followed up in writing on the US Senate
hearing and in one of these written
responses they said it was also the
topic was also shadow profiling the
tracking of non users across the
internet and
that's a standard feature of the
internet and Google also pointed like
Amazon does this Twitter does this etc
so in a way we need to reclaim the
internet like there's no natural law
that says that every website every app
we use
sends such detailed data to hundreds of
different companies every time you use
them so what can you do what can we do
so our response from Google said there's
two easy ways to fix this problem you
just you can locked out of add
personalization and you can reset your
ad ID so we gave that a shot see how
that works out so this what happens when
you opt out of AD personalization so the
top is with AD personalization on and
this is opted out it's a big improvement
there the the actual the real the real
improvement is that the flag has been
changed from true to false but the data
is increased and it's still being same
so yeah it's so you can't really opt out
then so your best bet well an audience
like this has probably got its one
advantage you've probably got if you've
got an Android phone is probably rooted
so you could always just block graft at
facebook.com/ I don't know what the what
the implications of that might be there
might be other stuff that just stops
working but but most users don't have
rooted phones and so you only other real
alternative is you could try no install
apps that use the Facebook SDK but good
luck working out which ones those are
because it's not well indicated on any
app I've ever seen so the only other
options you have is to minimize what
your the datee or your same thing so you
could segregate your apps have a
different profile in your Android device
for every app so that the yeah the
advertising IDs are separate and then
you you know your your ID will only
apply to that one out and obviously you
can always reset your ID and opt out it
doesn't really match but it does at
least you know it keeps your profile
fresh keeps the you know it's the time
frame that also makes quite a big
difference to how you are profiled
so but why should you have to do all of
this so I'm going to release all of my
environment you so anyone can we
replicate we've done I'm gonna do that
tomorrow because I need to get home and
sleep but so yeah I mean my environment
is going to go on the PI's website and
then all of our documentation is also
available on PI's website so if anyone
else wants to look through what all of
the apps we looked at don't do I
definitely suggest you have a look at
kayak and I just have a look at the LED
flashlight it's quite interesting
especially their consent slows but yeah
we also on tall
[Applause]
[Music]